I felt I had no choice I was losing my
artists Warhol was showing with the
stable gallery it was long before
Castelli took on Warhol Oldenburg was
showing with the green gallery and these
artists began to be collected the
magazines picked them up pop art was so
easy to reproduce because it was all
about being reproductions to begin with
so it became fashion it's the first time
that we really saw art and fashion meat
and I couldn't get the I think that the
work anymore and I actually moved to New
York too late if I would have moved to
New York when I opened the gallery I
would have had all of those artists
exclusively years later they came back
to me but there was great hiatus in
between because there were associations
that were made and you know you don't
break those but so I felt that I had no
choice but to move to New York and had a
very dear friend who's lived in the city
a father of a very dear friend and I was
staying with that one time when I was in
New York and and he was the head of
federated department stores and Sidney
Solomon and I said Sidney said - I said
- Sidney you know I'm thinking of moving
to New York thinking moving the gallery
to New York scary but I'm thinking
moving to New York
he said well you have to ask yourself
what is your objective what do you want
out of your gallery and I said I want to
be the best gallery in the world
he said moved to New York I get out of
Boston and I got out of both it was so
hard in Boston convincing people that
what I was doing was not insanity a very
conservative City
you've heard of them many times people
say the futures of the east you know
China is the next power the West
specifically America's power is
diminishing do you know when people say
things like that
it's already happened people only
recognize things that are cooked at our
that's a complete and there was very
interesting art happening in China and
you know interesting art happens usually
after a cataclysm or a war
it took the destruction of Germany for a
new generation of German artists to be
able to build something new and that was
non referential to the past or not
intimidated by the past in the same way
America had Abstract Expressionism which
was post-world War two China was
recovering from the Cultural Revolution
in a very interesting phenomenon I saw
happening and that was they had an
extraordinary narrative to tell there is
no excuse for a narrative in Western art
anymore you know we've been through that
and through kind of formalism and there
is no story to tell in the same way
China on the other hand when the doors
to China opened they looked across this
chasm of time at the achievement of
Western art and I spoken with several
Chinese artists and I remember one of
them saying to me when we saw from the
Renaissance to pop art we saw it as one
thing as one holistic accomplishment
they didn't see it really in us in the
time period or its historical context I
thought that was pretty interesting
because I thought of a parallel when
Picasso and Braque discovered
Chinese I've discovered African art and
they didn't understand this ritualistic
uses or weren't interested in its
ethnographical purposes they purely
formerly saw an art that they could use
a kind of cubistic art that they could
use in the development of their work and
the Chinese did the same thing they
looked across at all of these styles and
they took from the various styles of
painting but they told but they're
telling a very personal unfamiliar
narrative but in a medium that we can
all understand and that's the success of
Chinese art is this poignancy this kind
of sense of loss and regeneration is
being told in mediums that are familiar
to the West